yeah maybe she considers herself
bisexual well then she should say that
but i don't i'm a lesbian who had sex
with a man no such thing i had sex with
one man
you know if a gay man has sex with a
woman he was bored drunk lonely whatever
and if a lesbian has sex with a man her
whole life choice becomes suspect i
think it's i think you all are
giving me way too much i think you're
making up a bunch of excuses to hide
your desire for men why not just live
your life the way you want and don't
call yourself a lesbian yeah no one
would care who you have sex with as long
as you call yourself what you really are
why don't you all clue me in on what it
is i am and i would be happy to have to
have sex with a man a certain number of
times over a period of time to have your
identity as a lesbian question i think
it's a question of how you do it i don't
think she's really a dyke
i don't think she's strong enough to be
a dyke
no it's cool for her to do what she
wants but i wouldn't i don't want to
date anyone that close-minded you mean
you tell every woman you sleep with how
many men you've had sex with and how
recently no but i've probably had sex
with more women than anyone else in this
room and i'm not saying that quality
quantity is quality but it's a lot
harder to keep your identity as a single
lesbian than as some woman who's been in
a homey little relationship for 12 years
then the women you do have sex with
don't know what they're dealing with
well what's the likelihood of a woman i
meet tonight coming home with me if i
say listen i think you should know but
i've recently had sex with a man
very slim exactly exactly what it would
be dishonest not to tell her who the
hell wants to think about all the people
the person you're having sex with has
had sex with i don't know some people
get off on that no the point is she's
cute enough but if i thought she would
have the sudden urge to have sex with a
man while i was dating her i'd say
forget it you and i were in some
committed relationship i wouldn't be
having sex with anyone but you
but who's to say this little whim won't
pop up again i don't cheat on people
why is everyone actually like it's the
end of the world for her to have sex
with some stupid guy
i hate to picture having sex with a guy
if it means so little to you why are you
acting so guilty
did you enjoy it it wasn't bad did you
come no but i bet he did i wasn't in it
for an orgasm what were you in it for
sex
[Music]
you